Das Podcast Ufo. Das Podcast Ufo. Ich freue mich sehr, dass es wieder geklappt hat. Wir sind zwar an unterschiedlichen Orten auf diesem Planeten, aber wir sind verbunden und wir hören uns gut. Mein Name ist Stefan Tietze, gegenüber von mir rein virtuell sitzt Florentin Will und wir freuen uns auf eine spannende, picke-packevolle neue Folge, das Podcast UFO, euer Spaß-Podcast des Vertrauens. Ja, des Vertrauens ist mir ganz wichtig. Ich hoffe, dass wir das einlösen können, dieses Versprechen, dass ihr uns vertrauen könnt, dass ihr uns alles anvertrauen könnt, dass eure Geheimnisse bei uns sicher sind. Und ja, pickepacke voll hast du angesprochen, ich möchte es aufnehmen und weiterführen. Ja, wir haben eine Menge geplant für diese Folge. Ich bin gerade in Hamburg, ich hoffe, es heilt nicht so sehr. Meine Wohnung ist... Warum? Weil Hamburg heilt. In Hamburg
weiß ja jeder, heilt es ein bisschen. Man muss
in Hamburg ein bisschen leiser sprechen, sonst heilt es von allen
Wänden daher. Es ist so leer in Hamburg.
Hier ist... Da müssen... Wir brauchen ein bisschen...
Da muss ein bisschen was kommen. Die Regale
müssen gefüllt werden, die Strassen müssen voll werden.
Hier ist alles so leer und so offen.
Und genau so ist meine Wohnung auch.
Man muss es sagen, es ist mitten in der Nacht gerade,
mitten in der Nacht auf.
Das ist wie so eine Sleepover-Folge.
Ich stelle mir gerade vor, wie wir so ein Zelt gebaut haben.
Das ist auch so ein Ding, Zelte benutzt man zu 80 Prozent, so Wes Anderson-mässig, im Kinderzimmer, stellt man die auch. Ja. Und zu zehn Prozent liegen sie im Schrank, wobei eigentlich 80 Prozent liegen sie im
Schrank, zu 20 Prozent, 19 Prozent werden sie im Zimmer aufgebrannt, ein Prozent ist
mal der eine Campingurlaub, für das man sie gekauft hat. Zelte werden nicht benutzt für das, was ursprünglich geplant war, aber so stelle ich mich gerade vor, wir würden so eine Taschenlampe in so einem Zelt, aber im Zimmer gebaut haben. Weil ich will auch in dieser Vorstellung nicht frieren draußen. Ich kann das noch unterstützen, nämlich weißt du, was ich jetzt gerade mache? Ich lege mich gerade ins Bett rein. Du masturbierst. Ach so, was? Ich lege im Bett. Du liegst im Bett, während wir aufnehmen? Ich habe mich richtig eingekuschelt. Doch, ich habe ein ganz langes Kabel. Das ist unser Job. Ich habe ein ganz langes Kabel. Es war immer mein Traum, einen Job aus dem Bett zu machen. Ich habe mich oft beim Schlaflabor engagiert. Wurde leider. Ja, weil die auch, weil die Patienten da schlafen, nicht die, die im Schlaflabor arbeiten. Das ist nämlich nicht richtig. Wenn die schlafen würden, dann würde das ganze System nicht funktionieren, Flo. Das ist falsch verstanden. Da machst du eine sechsjährige Ausbildung zum Schlafarzt, nur um dann zu merken, wie, die dürfen schlafen, ohne was gemacht zu haben. Mein ganzes Studium war für'n Arsch! Was ist deine Top 3 an Berufen, die sich am Ende richtig wundern und es sich falsch anders vorgestellt haben? Ja. In schmissigen Listennamen. Ja, wir sind bei den schmissigsten angekommen jetzt. Aber in Folge 819 muss man auch irgendwann anfangen, sich Sachen sich auszudenken, und vor allem brauchen die auch Vorbereitungszeit, da fragst du mich aber jetzt aus der Hüfte. Ich würde gerne mal mit der drei anfangen, du kannst ja die zwei so reinschlüpfen. Platz drei der Berufe, wo man sich am Ende richtig mal umguckt und sich denkt, meine Herren, hätte ich das mal früher gewusst, dann hätte ich vielleicht einen anderen Lebensweg bestritten, eine andere Karriere oder eine andere Ausbildung, und zwar Kranfahrer. Habe ich letztens gesehen auf einer Baustelle, vielleicht der traurigste Anblick meines Lebens, ein Kranoperator mit einer Fernsteuerung steht am Boden, um mit einer Fernsteuerung den Kran zu fahren, wo ich mir denke, es gibt einen Grund, warum man Kranfahrer wird, einen einzigen, und zwar bis den ganzen Tag 150 Meter über an allen anderen, kannst laut sein, kannst nachdenken, kannst weit sehen, kannst einen schönen Podcast hören, dich kann niemand daran hindern, während der Arbeit einfach eine Packung Nicknacks zu essen. Kann dich niemand daran hindern. Niemand. Das ist auch mittlerweile auch bei Kampffiloten ja auch so. Weil Kampffiloten steuern auch mittlerweile diese dicken Väter, die man kennt, die auf dem Feld standen und ihrem Kind unter dem Vorwand, dem Kind eine Freude machen zu wollen, zu Weihnachten so ein ferngesteuertes Flugzeug geschenkt haben, dann aber natürlich selber den Rest des Jahres auf dem Feld stehen und das fernsteuern, so dicke Väter. Und das ist doch mittlerweile der Drohnen, das ist doch, wir brauchen noch, Kampf-Touch-Piloten sind doch irgendwie für den Arsch mittlerweile. Du kannst einfach nur eine Drohne steuern, fernsteuern, das ist ja nichts anderes. Oder braucht man das noch? Ich kenne mich ehrlich gesagt nicht so gut aus, aber ich habe traurig den richtigen Begriff. Ich glaube auch, dass einfach eine Fernsteuerung auch einfach, generell ist eine Fernsteuerung gut. Immer wenn mir jemand eine Fernsteuerung in die Hand drückt, habe ich erstmal ein positives Gefühl im Magen. Okay, jetzt kommt Fun in meine Richtung und die nehme ich gerne an. Aber ich glaube, bei manchen Sachen will es auch einfach keine Fernbedienung haben. Und Kranfahrer, und der sah richtig traurig aus, der stand auf dem Bau und kreist von seinen nervenden Kollegen irgendwie alle, ärgern sich, der Bauleiter ist so inkompetent. Und der hatte wirklich so einen, ah, wäre ich gerne in meinem Kranblick drauf und hat da ganz traurig mit dem Joystick dann so diesen riesigen Kran, der von unten unbezähmbar aussieht. Und man denkt sich, wer kann das überhaupt leisten, wer kann dieses Ungetüm überhaupt bezwingen? Joystick. Joystick, so ein gelangweilt mit einem mit Nick-Nack-Staub bedeckter Daumen, der auf diesem Joystick herumflitzt. Es ist traurig. Was ist dein Platz zwei? Mein Platz zwei ist Archäologen. Ich glaube nämlich, die kommen, die kommen alle aus der Zeit, in der Indiana Jones ein großer Hit war, wo man denkt, man läuft durch die Weltgeschichte herum, erlebt Abenteuer, trägt einen coolen Lederhut, trägt ein cooles Lasso, warum, weiß man nicht genau, oder so ein Peitschending. Ja, die Peitsche. Die Peitsche trägt so ein Leatherman-Säbel-Zahn-Messer, hat einen Haifischzahn umgeschnallt um den Hals und geht auf grosse Abenteuersuche. Ich glaube, das ist nicht der Fall. Ich glaube, es ist viel telefonieren mit Leuten, die nicht deine Sprache sprechen. Ich glaube, es ist die meiste Zeit, wartest du einfach auf den Einsatz, du sitzt viel rum und ich glaube, maximal zwei Prozent des Jobs sind es dann wirklich auszugraben.
Viel Pusten auch, viel Dreck wegpusten, viel Sand in der Wohnung. Ich glaube, es ist mit sehr vielen Nachteilen verbunden, über die ich mir gar keine Forschung machen möchte. Ich glaube, Archäologen sind wirklich die grosse Enttäuschung am Ende des Tages. Ich glaube aber auch, dass es jedes Jahr an den Universitäten der Welt immer ein sehr trauriger Moment ist, wenn die Neuankömmlinge der Archäologiestudiengänge ankommen und richtig freudend mit ihrer Peitsche am Gürtel den Vorlesungssaal betreten und einfach so eine große Kiste steht, wo man direkt die Peitschen ablegen kann, weil man sofort gesagt bekommt, nee, nee, keine Peitschen hier. Nein, keine Peitschen, erst morgen zum Peitschenkurs. Aber der ist nur ganz kurz und auch langweilig, weil man so einen blöden Lehrer hat. Da muss ein Tutor, muss dann immer so durch die Reihen laufen und die Peitschen abnehmen. Die kriegt ihr morgen wieder, hört mal, einmal höher, ganz kurz, bitte, die kriegt ihr alle morgen wieder beim Herrn Hessbacher. Herrn Hessbacher gibt immer zwei... Oh nein, nicht der olle Hessbacher. Ruhe bitte, Ruhe bitte, einmal, ich muss, ich sag's einmal für alle. Ritze, Ritze. Ey, bitte alle in die Kisten, morgen beim Herrn Hessbacher. Und das Messer aus dem Gesicht von der Nina. Dennis, nimm das Messer runter. Oh nein, da kommt dann doch ein großer Stein auf uns zugerollt. Lauft, lauft! Schnell, das hat mir geübt, lauft! So was Doofes. So, also, wenn ihr ins Grab von Tutank Amon läuft, nicht auf die Knöpfe drücken. Das ist offensichtlich, dass es immer kommt überall Gift raus, unten sind immer Skorpione oder Alligatoren oder Falltüren. Also an den Wänden langlaufen, alle zusammen. An den Wänden langlaufen. Wach, Entschuldigung, was mache ich denn, wenn ich in so eine Stachelgrube reinfalle, so eine aztekische Stachelgrube, wo schon so ein halbes Skelett aufgespießt ist. Ja, also erstmal erste Regel, keine Angst vor dem Skelett. Skelette, da passiert nichts, die sind tot, die sind alt. Wir sind Archäologen, ich bitte Sie, Herr Professor, wir haben doch keine Angst vor Skeletten. Ja, ich weiß nicht. Manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, ihr habt ja noch ein bisschen, habt ihr eine andere Vorstellung vom Job des Archäologen. Naja, also wenn ihr in so eine Grube fallt, einfach erst mal gucken, bewegen sich die Wände. Das ist immer das Wichtigste. Und ich sage euch, in 80 Prozent werden sich, ja, werden sich die Wände auf euch zubewegen. Aber kurz bevor sie ankommen bei euch und euch drohen zu zerquetschen, wird die Musik von John Williams in Höhepunkt erreicht haben und irgendwer aus der Gruppe, der nicht ihr seid, sondern jemand aus dem höheren Semester, der die Protagonist ist, der wird es schaffen, diese Vorrichtung zum Stehen zu bringen. Meistens mit so einem grossen Speer, was indogene Völker genutzt sind, um über Klippen zu springen. Das wird genutzt, um diese Wände aufzuhalten. Aber das lernt ihr auch. Das lernt ihr erst im sechsten Semester. Ach, es war eine schöne Zeit damals. Es war eine schöne Zeit. Ich bin euphorisiert. Der Tag fing nicht gut an. Was? Ja, ich komme gerade vom Sport. Und zwar habe ich heute zum ersten Mal in meinem ganzen Leben so einen ganz lächerlichen Fitnesskurs besucht, gerade eben. Es war grauenhaft. Aber wenn man durch ist damit, ist man euphorisiert. Hat auch, glaube ich, hormonelle Gründe. Ich glaube, das Gehirn stößt dann auch Endorphine und sowas aus beim Sport. Bin ich mir nicht sicher, ehrlich gesagt. Ich habe jedenfalls gerade eine Stunde lang Bodypump gemacht, das war ein, das war grauenhaft, wirklich grauenhaft. Es läuft furchtbare Musik, es läuft, wobei es stimmt nicht. Dann plötzlich lief Queen, das fand ich dann cool, und dann lief dann wieder andere blöde Popmusik, die ich nicht mochte, aber es war schon anstrengend und ich habe die meisten Sachen nicht bis zum Ende durchgehalten. Und da ist mir mal aufgefallen, ich mache jetzt schon ein bisschen länger Sport und ich versuche aktiv zu werden. Und der große Lifestyle-Stefan ist ja jetzt seit zwei Jahren ungefähr am Start. Und ich dachte, ich bin gut in Form mittlerweile. Nein, stellt sich raus, wenn man alleine irgendwo trainiert, ist man nämlich gar nicht. Ich bin viel zu gut darin, mich selber zu bescheissen. Weil man hat dann, dann da an und hatte man hat einen tag und dann sagt man nach drei wiederholungen aber dass du heute hier ist her geschafft hast und du bist ja auch mit dem fahrrad gekommen so da ist ja auch schon was verbrannt auf dem wege her dass du jetzt ob du jetzt fünf oder sechs wiederholungen machst ist doch auch scheißegal entspann dich mal der fakt dass du hier, dass du hier bist, zeigt doch, dass du bist auf dem richtigen Weg.
Und man ist viel zu clever, sorry für diese Arroganz, aber man ist viel zu clever, um sich Sachen auszudenken, um nicht aktiv zu sein, wirklich.
Und bei diesen Kursen hast du das ja nicht, weil da erstmal, du bist ja gar nicht der, der vorgibt, wie viel du machst, sondern da ist vorhin so eine Frau, die rumtanzt, mehr Gewicht hat auf diesem Handscheln als du und das wahrscheinlich dreimal am Tag macht. Und neben dir sind Kursteilnehmer, die das gleiche machen. Und es ist schon was anderes, als wenn du so Kursteilnehmer machst. Und ich dachte, es hört mich extrem. Aber ich glaube nicht so. Man muss aber dazu sagen, dass es echt gut ist, dass diese ganzen Lifestyle-Fitness-Sachen oft englische Namen haben, weil wenn es statt Bodypump einfach Körperpump oder Körperpumpe hieß, glaube ich, wäre das nicht so beliebt insgesamt. Ich glaube auch, Körperhebel, Körperpump, ja, nee, das funktioniert nicht. Englisch ist einfach die coolere Sprache und das haben die schon richtig hingekriegt. Aber mal ganz kurz auf dem Weg hierher haben wir kurz kommuniziert, wie wir gleich aufnehmen werden. Und da wurde mir wieder vor Augen geführt, dass wir schreiben, wir sind eine Generation, die vor allem miteinander textet, die vor allem auf einer schriftlichen Ebene miteinander kommuniziert.
Und da merkt man manchmal, dass diese Sprache Grenzen hat, weil du gesagt hast, du warst sauer auf Skype und hast gesagt, mir steht es bis hier.
Und das finde ich ein sehr gutes Beispiel dafür, dass man mit Texten oft an die Grenzen kommt.
So, dass man mit Texten oft an die Grenzen kommt. So, man lobt auch immer, wo wir gerade beim Thema Archäologie waren, man lobt immer die Ägypter etc. für ihre tolle Hieroglyphenkultur. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass die alles damit rübergebracht haben oder auch wir alles mit Wörtern rüberbringen konnten. Es sind dann sind dann auch Grenzen erreicht. Ich finde mir stets bis hier, finde ich ein ganz gutes Beispiel dafür. Bis wohin? Bist du sauer, bist du nicht sauer? Weiß ich nicht, sehe ich nicht. Ja, ist schwierig. Ja, ich habe den heute Morgen zurechtgewiesen und dann war der so klein. Der war dann so klein. Wie klein? Nee, der war noch ganz schön gross. Der hat solche Augen, gemacht, solche Augen. Welche? Welche? Wie? Manchmal geht es nicht. Aber da ist natürlich Videotelefonie auch besser. Und das finde ich aber auch ganz spannend, dass Videotelefonie, das sehe ich manchmal natürlich für Leute mit, für stumme Leute mit Zeichensprache, die auf Zeichensprache angewiesen sind,
da Videotelefonie ja perfekt ist, einfach wunderbar, die mussten bis dahin immer
so mit so Strichmännchen
oder mit so Linien oder so. Nein, die können
einfach schreiben. Ja, die mussten
dann halt so diese Handbewegungen, so linke
Hand hoch, rechte Hand und
jetzt können die mit dem Telefon einfach
zack, zack, zack. Das hilft
Leuten, die da an der Stelle keine Hilfe, da ist keiner Hilfebedarf. Die können einfach miteinander auch einfach schreiben. Ja, aber die können ja nicht ihre Zeichensprache schreiben, verstehst du? Ach du meinst, die müssen sich dann zu sehr umstellen. Ja, und das ist ja bestimmt so eine Fremdsprache eigentlich, da kommt es dann einfach nicht gut durch, die können sich dann nicht gut ausdrücken. Sorry, this is my second language. Ja. My first is this. Und dann kommen so wilde Bewegungen. Ja, wirklich. Ich bin auch wirklich, manchmal mache ich es mir auch echt schwer. Ich habe jetzt wieder den Schluss gefasst, zum hundertsten Mal, ha ha ha, dass ich wieder ein bisschen Französisch lernen will und ich höre da französische Podcasts, es gibt so Einsteiger-Podcasts, aber ich denke immer so meine Theorie zum Thema Sprachen. Es gibt den Punkt, ab dem man, also zum Beispiel, wir haben ja Englisch gelernt, glaube ich, hauptsächlich durch englische Medien, durch Filme, Serien und so weiter, Podcasts auch. Ah, yes, yes. Aber die ersten, Entschuldige, aber die ersten Filme, die du gesehen hast, hast du ja nicht zu 100 Prozent verstanden, sondern zu 60 Prozent. Aber du denkst dir, okay, den ersten Film verstehst du zu 60 Prozent, den zweiten Film verstehst du zu 62 Prozent. Und du kannst ja auch mit Untertiteln arbeiten, deutschen Untertiteln zuerst, dann englischen Untertiteln. Aber du brauchst, es gibt diesen Punkt, dieser Kipppunkt, ab dem du Filme anschauen kannst und dabei was lernst. Aber bis zu, sagen wir mal, 60 Prozent verstehst du einfach nichts und es ist frustrierend. Und ich gucke immer, ob ich schon den Punkt habe und höre dann immer in seriöse, also nicht in Anfänger-Podcasts rein, sondern in echte französische Podcasts. Aber es ist immer noch zu schwer. Aber wie suchst du denn dann? Also du suchst ja dann nicht nach Sprach-Podcasts, du suchst einfach nach, was das ist für Themen? Ja, das ist oft schwer und oft weiss ich ja nicht, was das Thema ist. Und dann denke ich mir, ah, interessant,
weil oft, das ist genau das Problem,
wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel einen Film, den du gut
kennst, wie Ocean's Eleven oder so, wenn ich
den auf Französisch schauen würde, würde
ich nichts lernen, weil ich weiss schon, was
die sagen, das heisst, ich muss überhaupt nicht
auf die Sprache hören, ich kann aus dem
Kontext mir perfekt erschliessen, was die
Leute sagen, das heisst, es macht gar keinen Unterschied,
ob ich ihn auf Französisch oder auf Spanisch oder auf Ägyptisch schaue.aue. Na, das weiß ich gar nicht. Ich glaube nicht, weil du bist ja faul, das Gehirn ist ja automatisch faul, sucht er den Weg des geringsten Widerstands. Und es ist viel einfacher, aus dem Kontext zu schliessen, was jemand gemeint haben könnte, als jetzt genau zu überlegen, was heißt dieses Wort und ich merke mir jetzt das Wort, das heißt bestimmt das. Und deswegen ist es ein Problem. Und was ich beim Podcast mache, denke ich immer so, es ist doch viel besser, wenn ich nicht weiß, worüber die reden, weil dann muss ich angestrengt zuhören und denken, was zu Hölle meine, was heißt dieses Wort? Aber da ist ja die gesprochene Sprache. Ja, wir sind hochrotem Kopfabend im Bett und hören es angestrengt zu. Nee, was? Sport! Nein! Philosophie! Oh, was heißt? Und da die gesprochene Sprache natürlich umso schwerer ist, weil es sehr schnell ist, höre ich die immer so auf halber Geschwindigkeit. Und dadurch hört sich das halt immer so, je m'appelle Bernard et aujourd'hui, und ich wirklich, ich döse dabei immer ein, lerne nichts. Ja, aber ich freue mich noch, wenn ich nicht fange,rlaub, wo du einfach dir das angeeignet hast, wo du einfach dir angeeignet hast, irgendwann in halber Geschwindigkeit Französisch zu sprechen, wie ich ja immer auch nicht weiß, bei dieser Lernen-App Japanisch, das war ja damals, das habe ich auch hier erzählt, man weiß ja nicht, was man sich daran lernen soll, weil man eignet sich ja an, wie es vorgesprochen wird. Ohio! So, das ist ja die Frage, da bin ich acht Oktaven höher, acht Energielevel weiter und da frage ich mich dann auch, also was ist denn davon jetzt Sprache und reicht es nicht einfach, Werner Herzog mässig die Buchstaben aneinander zu reihen und ich finde es total lustig, wenn du einfach dir aneignest, in halber Geschwindigkeit Französisch zu sprechen. Nicht für einen sehr langsamen Menschen. Ja, total. Aber das Problem ist, bei mir stellt sich dadurch auch unbewusst so ein bisschen die Erkenntnis ein, mein Gott, sind Franzosen langweilig. Ja, dusselig. Langweilig und dumm. Langweilige Dusselköppe. Und dann denkt man sich, und dann macht mein Kopf immer den nächsten Move, warum soll ich Sprache lernen, die nur langweilig und dumm. Langweilige Düsselköppe. Und dann denkt man sich, und dann macht mein Kopf immer den nächsten Move, warum soll ich eine Sprache lernen, die nur langweilige Idioten sprechen und ich bin schon wieder demotiviert. Weil alle Menschen trotteln sind, ja. Bist demotiviert. Und es ist immer so, ich weiß nicht, egal was ich mache, ich komme am Ende immer raus, mich dazu zu motivieren, es weniger zu machen. Aber das ist genau, was ich meine. Ich glaube, wir sind an irgendeinem Punkt, und ich glaube, wir sind nicht besonders intelligent, aber ich glaube, wir sind, und das hat viele Menschen, ich glaube, die meisten oder alle, die diesen Podcast hören, sind zumindest an dem Punkt, intellektuell genug, sich zu gut selbst zu verarschen. Ich glaube, unser Schweinehund, der immer so genannt wird, das ist nicht unbedingt nur Faulheit, es ist auch irgendwann, der Mensch ist einfach in irgendeinem Punkt zu intelligent, um wirklich noch fortschrittlich zu denken. Ich glaube, Fortschritt und Intelligenz schliessen sich ja so ein bisschen aus, weil ich glaube, du bist dann irgendwann zu gut, die Dinge zu rationalisieren. Und da fängst du so Bullshit-Ketten an, die aber ja zum Endeffekt immer haben, nichts mehr zu tun. Ich glaube, und deswegen neigen auch dann schlaue Menschen dazu, sich einzukerkern und nichts zu tun. Ja, aber es ist auch so, zum Beispiel kann ich manchmal nicht gut einschlafen und da werden mir dann auch immer viele Tipps gegeben und da gibt es dann bestimmte Atemtechniken, irgendwie so dann vier Sekunden Luft holen und dann zwei Sekunden vier, sieben, acht. Genau, vier, sieben, acht. Vier Sekunden Luft, sieben Sekunden anhalten, was ich super hart finde, und acht ausatmen. Sieben Sekunden anhalten, wenn du so hart? Ich finde acht Sekunden ausatmen hart. Also da muss man sich schon darauf konzentrieren. Das ist jetzt nicht unmöglich, natürlich, aber da muss man sich schon darauf konzentrieren. Und mein Problem ist immer, dass ich mir immer denke, also ich mache diese Technik und dann denke ich mir, klappt das? Bin ich jetzt müde? bin ich jetzt näher am Einschlafen, bin ich jetzt näher am Einschlafen als gerade? Ich mache so ein Mal. Und dann überdenkt man das die ganze Zeit. Wie soll das eigentlich funktionieren? Naja, vielleicht weil ich mehr Zeit damit verbringe, das auszuatmen oder Luft anzuhalten, als wirklich Luft einzuatmen. Vielleicht wird das so, dass mein Gehirn weniger durchblutet wird. Mein Gehirn muss ja durchblutet werden, wird beim Gehirn beim Schlaf nicht durchblutet, wird es weniger durchblutet und dann bin ich ich hellwach. Wo ist das Blut im Schlaf? Und dann ist YouTube an, Wikipedia offen, die Wohnung ist hell erleuchtet, Snickers im Mund. Aber dann ist auch immer so der Punkt, wo man denkt so, ich werde müde, ich werde müde. Oh, es klappt, es klappt, ich werde müde, es klappt, yes, es klappt. Und dann freue ich mich und dann bin ich wieder wach. Nein, bin wieder wach. Aber nochmal kurz zu Französisch und dann dachte ich mir so ein bisschen, weil ich will ja nicht so perfektes, also ich will ja gesprochenes Französisch verstehen, auch wenn ich Filme und so anschaue. Und dann dachte ich mir, okay, ich eigne mir französischen Slang an, damit ich gleich so von hey, what's up, dude? Ja, auch gut, dass du 18 Schritte überspringst, direkt darauf kommst. Ja, ich lerne Slang vor Vergangenheit. Also ich kann mich mit Jugendlichen unterhalten, aber nur wenn es um die konkrete Gegenwart geht, also nicht um die Vergangenheit der Zukunft. Und alte Menschen verstehe ich auch nicht. Und das Verstörende am französischen Slang ist, dass es eine bestimmte Art von französischen Slang gibt, und das ist total faszinierend.
Das ist deutsch.
Das sind einfach Englisch, einfach Begriffe. Und es nennt sich Verlant, sage ich jetzt mal, Verlan. Und die Technik besteht darin, dass man Worte umdreht, also die Silben umdreht. Also das kommt auch von Verlant, kommt von L'envers, was heißt so viel, wie heißt Backwards inverse, inverse geschrieben, backwards, das heißt, du sagst dann nicht keine Ahnung, du sagst dann nicht Auto, sondern Toao. Und das ist dann cool unter französischen Jugendlichen, die dann sowas umdrehen. Ja, kreil jetzt auf mit Französisch. Dieses Volk treibt dich nirgendwo hin. Und vor allem, du hast halt keine Chance, das zu verstehen, weil dazu musst du das Originalwort kennen, dann noch die Silben genau trennen können, dann sie rotieren können und das rückzudechiffrieren ist unmöglich. Und ich dachte mir einfach so, vergiss es einfach. Das ist wie Mathematik lernen, aber alle Zahlen sind Farben. Und go. Ja, und es ist so ein bisschen typisch für dieses Bild des arroganten Franzosen, der auch Leuten gar nicht will, dass man mit ihm Französisch spricht in Frankreich, sondern ihn einfach abschmettert, dass sie sich als Slang so eine Art Puzzle bedienen, wo man einfach jeden Ausländer sofort ausschliessert, wenn man keine Chance hat einfach. Und das wird dann teilweise, und noch cooler ist man dann, wenn man das dann noch komplizierter macht und dann in einem viersilbigen Wort das dann umdreht. Oder dann entsteht daraus aus den rotierten Silben entstehen wieder neue Wörter, die man dann wieder ersetzt durch ein Synonym dieses Wortes und das rotiert man dann auch wieder. Und das, glaube ich, das Ziel ist einfach vollkommen ein Unverständnis. Man versteht gar nichts mehr, was man sagt und man trifft sich auf dem Schulhof und man versteht nichts mehr. Kann es sein, dass während wir alle auf England geguckt haben mit Brexit, Frankreich einfach verrückt geworden ist? Kann das sein, dass man einfach, dass wir zu lange in eine Richtung geguckt haben? Ja, ich glaube auch, ich glaube auch, das ist so dieses alte deutsche Problem, dass wir umzingelt sind, geographisch. Und man denkt, ah, fuck, Russland aus dem Osten, Norden, England, Westen, Frankreich, und man kann sich immer nur auf einen konzentrieren. Und die Russen haben wir jetzt gerade mal so ein bisschen außen vor gelassen, Britannien und dann kommt Frankreich mit so einem Scheiß um die Ecke und es ist gnadenlos, also da gibt es, das ist eine eigene Wissenschaft für sich, diese Sprechtechnik und ob das ist nur so, also man kennt es ja so deutsche Jugendslang Bücher, die dann einfach realitätsfremd sind, ob das so ist, weiß ich nicht, aber es hat man einfach überhaupt gar keine Chance. Und ich dachte, man kommt da so rein, aber es geht nicht.
Mir ist heute Morgen, was seltsames passiert, und es passiert mir sehr häufig, mein Parfumflacon, wo wir gerade bei uns so geschwanden, heruntergefallen. Und es passiert sehr häufig und es ist nichts passiert, aber heute Morgen ist mein Parfum Flacon auf meinen Fliesenbeton, auf meine Fliesen gefallen und es zerschmettert. Und es war dieses, weil wir haben ja, es ist kurz nach Weihnachten und man weiß ja, ich kriege immer die grosse Version meines Parfums geschenkt von meiner Mutter. Jedes Jahr grösser, wie so ein Pokémon. Die ist jetzt runtergefallen. Und zum ersten Mal, und da hat mir das Leben bislang nicht gelehrt, dass es eine Option ist, ist die Flasche zerbrochen und es war komplett voll. Und da war richtig viel drin. Und mein ganzes Badezimmer, also erst mein Badezimmer heute Morgen, mittlerweile, ich bin heute nach Arbeit nach Hause gekommen und gegen so eine Wand Parfum-Geruch gelaufen. Das war wirklich, also unglaublich, wie meine Wohnung jetzt riecht. Und ich ziehe jetzt zum 1.3. aus, aus meiner Kellerwohnung neben der Pathologie. Und ich erwarte jetzt bald sehr viele Besuche für Nachmieter. Und ich bin echt gespannt, wie die darauf reagieren, weil ich glaube nicht, dass ich diesen Geruch jemals nochmal herausbekomme bis zum ersten dritten.
Naja, jetzt kannst du zwei verschiedene Fehler machen. Jetzt machst du entweder den ich arbeite geruchlich dagegen Fehler im Sinne von. Das mache ich seit sechs Jahren, arbeite ich geruchlich dagegen. Jetzt riecht es, glaube ich, normal. Jetzt, jetzt, du versuchst den Geruch auszugleichen, indem du jetzt irgendwie noch
einen anderen Geruch mit reinbringst, weil
ich meine...
Ah ja, das gibt es nämlich.
Was sind denn, wie man checkt, was Gerüche
genau sind. Doch, doch, doch. Gibt es denn nicht
Minus und Minus, ist Plus bei Gerüchen oder so?
So wie bei Farben? Es gibt nämlich
einen Parfüm-Kreis,
weil jedes, jeder, also das ist ja auch What? ja genau, das ist auch so eine Wissenschaft für sich, weil es ist ein bisschen wie Farben.
Jedes Parfüm lässt sich einordnen auf diesem Kreis. Es ist entweder zitrushaltig oder so moschusledrigerdig oder ein Mittelding oder es geht in eine andere Richtung, fruchtiger und dann gibt es orientalisch ist auch so eine Sparte und es wurde dann so ein Kreis bestimmt. Und ich weiss ja, was mein Parfüm ist und würde jetzt gerne mal davon das Gegenteil finden. Da gibt es eine Seite, ich weiss nicht genau, wie die heisst. Es gibt zu jedem Parfüm
Antiparfüm?
Flavorwheel heißt der, genau, Flavorwheel.
So, und da kann ich jetzt meinen
finden, glaube ich.
So, jetzt habe ich den hier,
also den Flavorwheel habe ich
jetzt schon mal gefunden. Aber wie soll
das denn gehen? Weil was, Geruch sind doch
irgendwie so kleine Partikel in der Luft oder so.
Ja, ja. Aber, also
ich meine, ich kann verstehen, dass jetzt wie wir
wollen wir mal nicht päblicher sein als der Papst.
Aber jetzt, ich kann mir verstehen, wenn man so
Noise-Canceling-Kopfhörer hat, so mit Wellen
und dann hast du die versetzte
Welle, die sich dann ausgleichen. Aber
wie geht das denn, wenn du mit so Partikelzeugen
in der Luft, du kannst ja nur mehr Partikel
dazutun, wie canceln die sich aus?
So.
Oh Gott, jetzt haben wir
den Höllenkreis der
Parfümerie aufgemacht und ich glaube, wir kriegen
so dermassen wohlformulierte
und samtzarte Mails
diese Woche, dass ich sehr gespannt
bin, wie wir da
darauf kommen.
Ich finde jetzt auch einfach nicht mehr diese Website, ist ja auch egal. Ich würde mal sagen... Ja, aber Flavor Circle habe ich auch, aber Flavor Circle habe ich gefunden. Das ist ja verrückt. Ah, hier gibt es einen Tea-Coffee-Flavor-Wheel. Das Gegenteil von Citrusfrucht ist zum Beispiel Pfeffer. Und ich sehe, wie das zusammenpasst. Nein! Aber das cancelt sich aus, oder was? Jetzt bin ich doch bei Geschmack, meine Freunde. Ich bin falsch abgewogen an jeder Stelle. Moment, aber soll das heissen, Pfeffer und Zitrone cancelt sich aus gegenseitig? Komplementär. Ja, aber komplementär heisst ja nicht nur, dass es sich auscancelt. Weil ich esse ganz gern schön Avocado mit Zitrone und Pfeffer.
Wir vergleichen uns ja gerade mit Farben.
Und Farben gleichen sich ja auch nicht aus.
Die ergeben einfach was anderes.
Also die passen gut zusammen.
Die passen zusammen.
Ja, okay.
Das sehe ich. Kann ich verstehen auf eine Art.
So hier, Röstaromen.
Hier zum Beispiel Tabak oder verbranntes Asche, Smoky, Smoky-Gedöns, Barbecue, ist das Gegenteil von Apfel, Pineapple, Cherry. Oh, ich sehe schon mich herumexperimentieren mit Geschmäckern jetzt. Das ist wirklich verrückt. Also hier hast du... Da, hier ist Beanie, Stale, Cardboard. Also zum Beispiel... Ja, würde ich jetzt nicht essen, Cardboard. Papier passt gut zum Rosé. Ich habe mal geguckt, also hier unter der Überkategorie Chemical gibt es Salty.
Und genau gegenüber von Salty steht Kokosnuss, steht Fruity. Also Fruity und Salty passen gut zusammen. Hier steht Ananas und Raisin, ja, also Rosinen und Salz. Aber bist du dir wirklich sicher, dass es heißt, dass die gegenüberliegenden sich gut kombinieren lassen? Ich wüsste sonst nicht, was das bedeuten soll, dieser Kreis. Jetzt habe ich es gefunden für Fragrances. Genau, und zwar meins ist, würde ich jetzt mal sagen, Richtung, also so citrusaromatisch und dann geht es schon in diese woody-Richtung. Und das Gegenteil davon wäre halt so floral oriental oder soft floral. Das heißt, ich bräuchte vielleicht so Darf Himbeer. Du brauchst so ein ganz zartes Rosenblumenparfüm.
Blumenparfüm. Aber die kann man genau finden, ja, hier sehe ich es ja genau. Genau, hier, Jihan von Kajal. Ach, das ist echt eine spannende Seite. Die Seite heißt Fragrances of the World, da kann man sich ganz gut durchklicken. Es ist wirklich eine Wissenschaft und ich kann mir auch, das ist wirklich sowas, da kann ich mir vorstellen, dass das, weiß ich nicht, aber beim Daten kann ich mir vorstellen, hilft ein Parfum dann doch ein bisschen, glaube ich. Also du musst wissen, welches Parfüm dein Datepartner hat und dann kannst du das Komplementäre dazu tragen, so dass man sofort zusammen gut riecht, oder wie? Oder sich abstösst. Das gilt es jetzt noch herauszufinden. Weiß ich nicht. Ja, aber wenn man sich gegenüber abstossen würde, was wäre dann Komplementär? Also wenn es beim Farbkreis ist, dann muss es ja eigentlich gegenüberliegend gut zusammenpassen. Aber es ist eine interessante Idee. Müssen wir mal ausbilden. Vielleicht hat man auch einfach einen Kreis gewählt, weil es einfach eine schöne Form ist. Oder Thais testet das mal. Die kommt ja auch langsam ins Alter, wo sie dann auch mal feiern gehen kann, schön. Und dann kann sie das mal ausbilden. Ich glaube, Thais hat bis jetzt schon mehr gefeiert als wir in unserem gesamten Leben. Das ist völlig richtig wahrscheinlich. Jedenfalls riecht man in der Wohnung jetzt ganz stark parfümiert. Und ich habe Fenster aufgemacht in alle Richtungen. Und ich glaube, jetzt riecht mittlerweile die ganze Strasse nach diesem Parfüm. Aber auf eine Art auch irgendwie ganz nett. Ich beklage mich darüber jetzt auch nicht. Finde ich nicht so schlecht. Die Scherben waren nur unangenehm. Naja, aber das war auf jeden Fall, so fing mein Tag heute an. Und das Problem war, ich musste auch relativ schnell los. Heißt, es lag dann den ganzen Tag lag da diese Pfütze rum und mittlerweile ist sie auch einfach eingetrocknet und das ist auch ein Problem für die Nachmieter. An irgendeinem Punkt ist auch egal, an irgendeinem Punkt bedeutet mir diese Wohnung auch nichts mehr. Ich bin da sehr schnell, ich bin sehr schnell, mich emotional für etwas zu lösen. Kann ich sehr gut. Aber ich ziehe um, zum ersten dritten und bin da sehr gespannt. Ich freue mich sehr und bin jetzt in so einer stressigen Phase, wo man sich damit jetzt auseinandersetzt, wie man diese Wohnung einrichten will, man überlegt schon, wie man den Umzug organisiert und so und jetzt werden die Umzugskretons gepackt. Er ist mein zweiter Umzug erst in meinem Leben. Ich bin meistens längere Zeit da, wo ich dann immerhin sehe.
Bist du auch umgezogen? Hont gepackt. Es ist mein zweiter Umzug erst in meinem Leben. Ich bin meistens längere Zeit da, wo ich dann immerhin siehe.
Bist du auch umgezogen?
Ja, schon ein paar Mal. Aber die neue Wohnung, die hast du jetzt für den Rest deines Lebens gedacht? Oder was ist so die Zeitspanne, die du dir vorstellst für diese Wohnung?
Zehn Jahre.
Zehn Jahre? Okay.
Zehn Jahre. In der neuen Wohnung wird es schwer mit Kind zum Beispiel. Das würde schwierig werden, weil ich glaube, da ist einfach kein Platz für ein Kinderzimmer, das ist keine Wohnung für ein Kind. Und da muss man glaube ich dann umziehen. Deswegen, ich denke so in zehn Jahre Schritten.
Und wegen der Pole-Dance-Stange dir vielleicht so ein bisschen kritisch. Ja, die hilft jetzt auch nicht.
Ich hatte so ein unangenehmes Erlebnis letztens im Zug.
Pole-Dancing-Erlebnis?
Es war ein Pole-Dancing-Erlebnis, wirklich so.
Und zwar fahre ich im Zug und dann kommt so eine junge Frau auf mich zu und sagt, haben Sie kurz Zeit für eine Umfrage. Und da der Zug Verspätung hatte und ich dachte, dass es um eine Bahnumfrage geht, dachte ich mir, so, Fräulein, also, ich werde Ihnen jetzt mal schön meine Meinung sagen, ja, weil so geht's nicht. Ja, nicht nur, dass der Gleiswechsel nicht in der App angezeigt wurde, nicht nur, dass der Zug einem anderen Bahngleisteil gehalten hat, als es eigentlich in der Infografik steht, so dass ich mich genau dahingestellt habe, wo mein Waggon gebucht war und ich dann der, der einmal über den kompletten Bahnsteig wetzen musste, obwohl ich der einzige war, der sich beschäftigt hat und dann auch noch zu spät und dann auch noch ein Halt ausgefallen.
Sage ich ja, okay, ich würde gerne teilnehmen.
Drückt sie mir einen Fragebogen in die Hand, überschrieben mit Pole Dance in der Gesellschaft.
Aber das ist auch unfair, du musst es erst amolieren, du kannst das nicht nachreichen, diese Info. Und dann war das anscheinend eine Umfrage über Pole Dance. Und dann war die erste Frage, welche Associtationen haben sie zu Bild A? Ich gucke diesen Fragebogen an, es ist kein Bild, nur Text. Dann gucke ich sie an, Bild A, und dann kramt sie aus einer Mappe ein mit Klarsichtfolie umwickeltes Bild raus und zeigt es mir. Und es ist eine ... Laminiert? Einlaminiert? Nee, nur in so eine so ein bisschen krösslige Klarsichtfolie, wo man Sachen reinschieben und wieder rausziehen kann mit so Ringen an der Seite.
Hält mir also das Bild vor von einer leicht bekleideten Tänzerin, die sich an einer Poledance-Stange räkelt. Und jetzt hast du mehr Puzzleteile und du setzt zusammen, ah, die ist wahrscheinlich eine Studentin, die eine Arbeit schreibt, darüber, wie Poldance in der Gesellschaft wahrgenommen wird.
Das war wahrscheinlich auch ihr Einstiegssatz, aber gut, das ist dann zusammengesetzt. Nee, das war nicht Ihr Einstiegssatz, überhaupt nicht. Gar nicht. Deswegen habe ich auch erst gesagt, ach es geht gar nicht um die Bahn, nee.
Und dann war in meinem Kopf sofort wieder der klassische Overthinker so, ah, wahrscheinlich will sie in ihrer Bachelorarbeit beweisen, dass das viele mehr so als so ein Schmuddelthema wahrnehmen, obwohl es eigentlich eine ernstzunehmende Sportart ist. Vielleicht macht sie auch selber Pole Dance und ärgert sich darüber, dass sie dann so als schlüpfriges Rotlichtding gesehen wird, obwohl es eigentlich sehr athletisch fordernd ist und all dieses. Und ich denke mir über all das nach. Und ich weiß, ich bin, ich studiere keine Psychologie, ich kenne mich damit nicht aus, aber ich kann mir vorstellen, dass die Ergebnisse eines Tests etwas verfälscht sind, wenn die Leiterin des Tests direkt neben einem steht, mit dem Bild in der Hand einen Anstarrt, während man diesen Fragebogen ausfüllt, sie auch sieht, was man schreibt.
War sie die Tänzerin auf dem Bild? Ich glaube nicht, ehrlich gesagt. Ich glaube nicht. Und also meine Assoziation zu dem ersten Bild. Und also die Assoziation ist schon so dermaßen verfälscht, dass es eigentlich unnütz ist. Also ich schreibe das Wort athletisch, weil ich eigentlich schon weiß, wo es hingeht. Und ich dann gar nicht mehr und mir, weil ich habe keine Meinung zu Polens, um ehrlich zu sein. Ich habe wirklich keine Meinung, mir ist das egal. Also ich habe schon immer so ein paar Gifs gesehen von so diesen Poledancerinnen, die dann so durch die Luft laufen. Und das ist total beeindruckend, was sie nicht für den Körperbeherrschen haben und so. Aber mir ist es im Grunde egal. Dann schreibe ich athletisch. Und dann zweite Frage, was ist ihre Assoziation zu Bild B? Selbes Spiel, er hat Bild B, sie kramt ein zweites Bild raus. Auch wieder eine junge, attraktive Frau, die sich an einer Stange räkelt. Was ist der Unterschied? Hat sie weniger an, ist ein Muster zu erkennen? Ich würde sagen, dass es eher ein Strip-Kontext ist. Aber nicht offensichtlich so. ist einfach vielleicht ein bisschen knapper bekleidet, ein bisschen laszivere Blick, sowas in der Richtung. Lasziv ist auch ein gutes Wort gewesen. Also was assoziieren Sie zu Bild B? Ich schreibe athletisch. Ich schreibe wieder athletisch. Und dann die Frage, die mir dann wirklich mich schachmatt gesetzt hat. Warum haben Sie Bild A mit einem anderen Wort assoziiert als Bild B? Und ich dachte mir, okay, du hast mich. Game over. Ich gebe auf. Ich gebe auf, nimm mich mit, verhafte mich. Ich habe verloren. Verhafte mich mit deinen Plüschhandschellen. Das war's, ich habe verloren, du hast mich in die Ecke gedrängt, das war's. Ich lasse also frei, beende diesen Fragebogen noch mit, wie viel Kontakt haben sie dazu, und dann vor allem, welche der folgenden Aussagen würden sie zustimmen? Pole Dance ist nur was für dreckige Schlampen. Okay, ich kann mir vorstellen, in welche Richtung diese Aussage geht. Und im Grunde war es eine Farce, eine absolute psychologische Farce. Ich meine, Psychologen sind natürlich clever, die testen oft andere Dinge als die, die man denkt, dass getestet werden. Das ist oft so, dass man dann denkt, man macht einen Test über X, aber eigentlich ist es ein Test über was anderes. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie irgendwelche genialen Hinterpläne hatte oder ob sie einfach ihre Bachelorarbeit schreibt und auf der Zugfahrt einfach noch 30 Blätter ausfüllen musste, weil ihr Professor sagt, sie brauchen 100 Blätter oder was. Also eine absolute Farce und mir so unangenehm und sie stand die gesamte Zeit, während ich es ausgefüllt habe, neben mir und ich war schon so kurz davor zu sagen, so vielleicht ist es für die Ergebnisse nicht ideal, wenn man als Versuchsleiterin daneben steht, aber ich dachte mir dann auch, nee, komm, ich muss jetzt nicht ihren Job erklären, so, ist mir dann auch egal. Nee, du musst dich da rumsplayen. Nee, das muss ich da nicht, aber es war einfach so unangenehm, es ist halt wirklich das Thema, was man am wenigsten erwartet. Ja, aber das ist wirklich tatsächlich, ja, war auch eine spannende Idee, das im Zug zu machen und einfach so gefangene Leute. Es ist schon clever auf eine Art, vor allem weil sie ein gewisses Ergebnis auch provozieren will. Man kann ja sogar Kalkül unterstellen und die wissenschaftliche Arbeit. Und ich freue mich schon auf die Bildschlagzeile, dass irgendwie herauskommt, dass mittlerweile Pole Dancer eher als athletisch wahrgenommen werden. Ja, neue Studie ergibt. Ästhetisch, schön, als lasziv und erotisch, weil, und sie das provoziert so ein bisschen, auch weil sie daneben steht und gefangene Leute im Zug anspricht. Naja, aber das ist so ein bisschen das Fundament der wissenschaftlichen Arbeiten, ist für mich auch so ein bisschen mittlerweile so, zumindest meine Frage zu stellen, weil alle Leute, die ich kennengelernt habe, und das ist ja nun mal die Bildungselite Deutschlands, die Studenten an Hochschulen und alle, die ich kennengelernt habe, schreiben eigentlich nur über Dinge, die sie selber interessiert. Ja, das ist ein Riesenproblem. Wir kriegen ja oft selber auch auf Bachelorarbeiten zu Podcasts uns zu zugeschickt. Und ich habe schon mal gesagt, die sind alle Crap. Sorry, aber die sind alle Crap. Tut mir leid an die fünf Studenten, die ich jetzt vielleicht beleidige, aber es sind alle Crap. Und man merkt es einfach, dass die einfach gerne Podcasts aufzählen, die sie gerne hören und über Namen schreiben, die sie selber gerne mögen. Aber es hat keine wissenschaftliche Intention ist einfach nur, ah, damit kenne ich mich aus, da kann ich einfach
eine Arbeit drüber schreiben. Ja, ich will, genau, ich will Zeit,
genau, bei meiner Arbeit
will ich Zeit mit etwas verbringen, was ich eh gerne mag.
Prinzipiell nicht so schlecht.
Also, das, womit man
genau schlecht, das ist genau das Gegenteil.
Nein, ich weiss, ich weiss, das war,
also, prinzipiell ist es aber nicht
schlecht fürs Leben,
einen Weg einzuschlagen, beruflich, der zumindest mal in die Richtung geht, was man macht, wenn man prokrastiniert. Das finde ich nämlich sehr gut, weil ich glaube, da hat man die meisten Talente drin und da kann man viel finden und in diesem Bereich grob, abstrakt. Aber wissenschaftlich ist das natürlich das grösstmögliche Hindernis, weil da fehlt ja jegliche Objektivität und jegliche wissenschaftliche Intention. Das ist ja völliger Humbug. Und deswegen war wissenschaftliches Arbeiten auch nie für mich, um ehrlich zu sein. Da habe ich auch keine guten Sachen fabriziert jemals, muss man echt sagen. Ne, man ist ja auch voreingenommen. Also du willst ja eigentlich dich mit einem Thema beschäftigen, das dich überhaupt nicht interessiert, wo du keine emotionale Bindung dazu hast,
damit du am Ende auch einfach sagen kannst, Podcasts sind
doof, auch wenn du es persönlich
gerne magst. Aber soll ich dir, soll ich mal
ganz ehrlich sein, was meine
tatsächliche Assoziation zu dem
ersten
Foto der Pole Dancerin war? Ja, hot as
fuck. Feuerwehr.
Feuerwehr?
Feuerwehr. Feuerwehr. Weil die doch auch immer an so Stangen runterrutschen, wenn die einen Einsatz haben. Das war meine echte erste Assoziation. Also dein Gehirn funktioniert assoziativ noch wie das eines Dreijährigen. Dein Gehirn ist noch nicht durch die Pubertät gegangen. Aber es zeigt mir, dass ich jegliche Studie, die auf Fragebögen aufbaut, nicht ernst nehmen kann.
Weil die Leute bewerten ja ihre Assoziation und sagen, nee, das ist so bescheuert, das kann ich jetzt nicht hinschreiben.
Auch wenn sie das vielleicht weitergeholfen hätte in ihrem Facharbeiter, Bachelorarbeit oder was auch immer, wenn da Leute Feuerwerk geschrieben oder Batman.
70 Prozent der Befragten assoziierten Batman.
Ja, oder so Klarsichthülle oder sowas.
Ich verstehe aber.
Ja, Bahnfahrt.
Ja, Bahnfahrt, Ausstieg, Verspätung.
Genau, Gleiswechsel.
Aber das ist wirklich, ja, das stimmt schon auf eine Art, aber bei einem Fragebogen, wo dich niemand beobachtet, machst du das ja auch.
Da würdest du ja Feuerwehr hinschreiben, ist ja scheissegal. Du bewertest das ja nicht, da steht ja nicht mehr ein Name drauf. Aber wenn die neben dir steht, schreibst du ja nicht Feuerwehr. Aber das wäre ...
Weiss ich nicht.
Oder fällt was auch ihr Weg, um einen Mann kennenzulernen?
Wie gut ist das denn, Bilder von sich, also ein Hobby von sich zu zeigen und dann Assoziationen zu mir. Und dann letzter Punkt, bitte schreiben Sie Ihre Handynummer. Ja, super, genau, damit ich Sie noch kontaktieren kann. Einfach so eine super elevated Anmache im Kern vielleicht einfach. Gar nicht so schlecht. Gute Idee. Aber ja, es hat nicht funktioniert und ich weiß nicht, was daraus wird.
Aber wie gesagt, vielleicht ist es ja auch oft, wenn man dann so eine psychologische Studie liest und dann heißt es so, ja, den Probanden wurde gesagt, dass es darum geht, jetzt irgendwie Gruppenarbeit zu erforschen. Und eigentlich ging es darum, wie viele Kekse die essen, während sie arbeiten und welche Gruppe mehr Kekse isst.
Und da steht halt ein Teller Kekse auf dem Tisch und so. Und was sie in ihrer Gruppenarbeit machen, ist vollkommen irrelevant.
Aber deswegen so dachte ich mir auch immer so, dass es eigentlich, es sind Psychologen einem immer einen Schritt voraus, die machen immer irgendwas krasseres.
So ein Kontinent, der uns vielleicht allen einen Schritt voraus ist, ist der wundervolle Kontinent Afrika. Denn hier ist Antenne Afrika. Ja, Afrika, ein Kont, ein mysteriöser Kontinent vor allem für europäische Leute wie uns, die keine Ahnung haben von Afrika und denken, Afrika ist ein Land, ist nicht der Fall. Afrika besteht aus 55 wundervollen Ländern und wir werden uns in unserer Kategorie Antenne Afrika immer mal wieder mit einzelnen Ländern beschäftigen. Genau, und da habt ihr uns schon ganz viele tolle Beiträge geschickt aus diversen Ländern, die wir gleich am Ende dieser Kategorie immer noch aufzählen werden, damit die nicht in Verzugessenheit geraten. Und in dieser Kategorie kriegen wir ganz viele tolle Beiträge von euch. Und auch heute hat uns wieder ein Hörer von euch einen ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz tollen Beitrag geschickt. Und zwar vielen Dank an Julian, Hörer Julian an dieser Stelle, und der hat uns was zu erzählen zu dem fantastischen Land Äthiopien. Entschuldigung, geht's ein bisschen leiser? Hallo! Hallo! Ah, geht doch. In Äthiopien ist jedes traditionelle Lied gefühlt fünfzehn Minuten lang und meist sehr eintönig. Beim dazugehörigen Tanz wird viel mit den Schultern gearbeitet, in Äthiopien ist eben vieles anders, vielleicht weil es das einzige Land in Afrika ist, das nie kolonialisiert wurde, vielleicht weil es mehr als einhundertzwanziganzig Ägnen gibt. Und das Ganze fängt schon bei der Sprache an, davon gibt es nämlich etwa achtzig Stück in Äthiopien. Die Amtssprache heisst Amharisch, nur sprechen die nur etwa fünfundzwanzig der gut einhundert Millionen Einwohner Äthiopiens. Englisch kann kaum einer, dazu haben die äthiopischen Sprachen eine eigene Schrift. Die Kommunikation hier ist also eine echte Herausforderung. Das hier, das klingt eher wie ein Muezzin, ist aber die Stimme einer äthiopisch-orthodoxen Kirche, mehr als die Hälfte der Äthiopier sind Christen, etwa ein Drittel Muslime.
Politisch ist Äthiopien weitgehend stabil.
Ministerpräsident Abiy Ahmed hat für seine Friedensbemühungen, unter anderem in Konflikt mit Eritrea, den Friedensnobelpreis bekommen.
Trotzdem gibt es noch immer ethnische Konflikte, und so kann es sein, dass man mit dem Bus auf einer Fahrt durchs Land in einem Dorf stecken bleibt, weil Studenten gegen den Präsidenten demonstrieren. Zum Reisen wird Äthiopien aber immer gefragter, die Landschaft ist faszinierend.
Die Simien Mountains sind das höchste Gebirge des Kontinents, die Danakil-Wüste der heisseste Ort der Welt,
Addis Abeba eine wachsende Metropole, die historischen Städte von Axum oder Lalibella sind UNESCO-Weltkulturerbe.
Zwar wächst die Wirtschaft rasant, die Chinesen bauen überall,
trotzdem ist Äthiopien noch immer eines der ärmsten Länder der Welt. Aber es ist ein Land im Umbruch. Wow, vielen, vielen Dank, Julian. Das war ein toller Beitrag. Wahnsinn, wie kann das nun funktionieren, dass so viele Sprachen gesprochen werden? Ich meine, dass Äthiopien auch das Lieblingsland war von Farin Urlaub, der mal irgendwann in einem Beitrag, den kann man auch bei YouTube finden, alle Länder Afrikas kurz mal beschreibt, oder die meisten.
Und da ist, glaube ich, Äthiopien auch mit sein Lieblingsland, weil er sagt, das ist landschaftlich so toll und so divers auch. Ich glaube, das wird von meinem Reise wert.
Können wir ganz kurz ...
Eines meiner Top-Ziele, wenn man nach Frankreich, nach Afrika fährt. Können wir ganz kurz eine kleine Top-Liste einschieben? Du meinst die bisher schönsten Länder? Nee, ich würde sagen die Top-Zwei der Länder, die mit einem Umlaut anfangen. Oh. Was ist da bei dir auf Platz zwei? Äthiopien ist für mich auf Platz zwei. Und auf Platz eins der Länder, die mit einem Umlaut anfangen, Österreich. Österreich. Jetzt wünschte ich, ich hätte doch mit Österreich angefangen. Aber warum findest du Österreich jetzt doch besser als Äthiopien? Naja, gut, ich war noch nie in Äthiopien. Vielleicht muss ich mal Julian in Äthiopien besuchen, um das näher sagen zu können. Gibt es doch ein anderes Land mit einem Umlaut? Österreich, Äthiopien, Ägypten! Ägypten, nee, E. Ägypten! Eritrea? Nee, Eritrea. Eritrea, ja, das kommt noch. So, dann können wir jetzt unsere feierliche Aufzählung machen, denn ich lerne die Länder Afrikas und ich merke mir Namibia.
Ich lerne die Länder Afrikas und ich habe viel gelernt über Namibia und Uganda.
Ich lerne die Länder Afrikas und merke mir Namibia, Uganda und Tansania. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob dazwischen noch eine Folge kam, aber ich lerne Länder Afrikas und nehme mit Namibia, Uganda, Tansania und Äthiopien, Ruanda? Nee, wir haben Ruanda vergessen. Ruanda! Wir lernen Ruanda. Ich lerne die Länder Afrikas und ich merke mir Namibia, Uganda, Tansania, Ruanda und Äthiopien. Man muss aber auch sagen, dass sie es einem nicht leicht machen. Es ist ein bisschen wie die Franzosen, die jetzt anfangen, ihre Wörter neu durchzumixen. So ist es auch ein bisschen mit Afrika, aber von Geburt an, weil es klingt vieles einfach sehr gleich. Kongo, Bongo, Uganda, Ruanda, es ist alles irgendwie noch, also da kommen natürlich sehr divers die Namen, die noch kommen. Ich denke an Elfenbeinküste, ich denke an Marokko und so weiter. Aber da so speziell bei den Ländern, so Ruanda, Uganda, da ist schon noch eine Menge, was da noch so kommt, was so ähnlich klingt.
Für mich schwierig, aber wir lernen das ja hier, dafür sind wir ja da.
Es ist aber ein schlechtes Zeichen, dass wir jetzt schon überfordert haben, wo wir gerade mal ein Elftel der 55 Länder Afrikas haben,
aber mehr über all diese Länder lernen wir in der nächsten Ausgabe von Antenne Afrika. Das ist meine neue Lieblingsrubrik. Auch wegen des Zünders. Ja, wir haben noch 50 Folgen vor uns, also genieß es, Stefan. Übrigens, falls ihr uns einschicken wollt, einen kleinen Beitrag zu einem Land Afrikas, gerne kurz davor noch mal fragen, ob wir nicht schon einen Beitrag dazu haben. Nicht, dass ihr euch die Mühe umsonst macht. Einfach kurz durchklingeln, einfach kurz bei der Zentrale melden, zentrale at podcast-ufo.fail, da könnt ihr alle Gingfurs. Oder direkt bei Flo und dem Handy. Die Nummer werde ich in den Kommentaren nachreichen. Ich war richtig starstruck diese Woche. Wen hast du getroffen? Otto Walges. Ich hätte nicht gedacht. Nee, ich hätte nicht gedacht. Ich hätte nicht gedacht, aber ich war starstruck. Ich war nämlich in Berlin am Dienstag. und zwar war da die Premiere der alljährlichen Dota-Dokumentation TrueSight, die immer eine Dokumentation über das grösste Dota-Turnier des Jahres ist. Und ich war da und es waren die beiden Finalistenteams da. OG, mein absolutes Lieblingsteam, Dota und ehemals Liquid Nigma waren auch da. Das heißt, neun absolute Dota-Legenden waren dabei. Hast du No-Tail gefunden? Ja, ich habe No-Tail gesehen natürlich. Und es waren alle da und es war grossartig. Und ich bin viel zu früh gekommen, weil ich natürlich dachte, es gibt eine riesige Schlange und ich will einen guten Platz haben, freie Platzwahl, und war davor schon so ein bisschen, da bin ich schon so ein bisschen im Location rumgeschlichen, weil ich dann wissen wollte, okay, wann kommen die Spieler, kann ich da einen abfangen irgendwie, habe dann da schon so ein bisschen Dota-Prominenz gesehen, so berühmte Caster und Content Creator und so und lauft da um dieses Kino rum, es war in dem Kino die Premiere, lauft da rum und plötzlich fährt da so ein Auto vor, ich dachte, wow, das ist echt ein edles Auto. Fährt da vor, direkt hinten, so ein Hintereingang von dem Kino, fährt vor, Tür geht auf und aussteigen tut. Götz Altsmann. Bitte. Und ich dachte mir, was ist los? What? Ich war komplett hin und weg. Aber da treffen wir zwei ganz verschiedene Welten aufeinander gerade.
Und ich musste instinktiv losbrusten, weil ich dachte, der kommt nicht zu dem Event, oder? Der ist jetzt hier nicht als Side Entertainment eingeladen. Es war grossartig und ich war so in dieser Dota-Welt und man hatte dann so einen Scanblick. Man guckt an die Leute und guckt, ja, weil Dota-Spiel war, OG verändert auch gerade ihr Team und da gibt es dann neue Spieler und du denkst, okay, wer könnte es sein, vielleicht ist jemand hier und so. Und dann guckst du dich um und siehst einfach Götz Altmann und es war grossartig und ich war, ich war wie eingefroren, als ich ihn gesehen habe, es war grossartig. Aber tatsächlich, Starstruck war ich, als ich die Spieler gesehen habe und es gab danach noch eine Fotosession.
Man konnte Fotos machen. Mit Götz-Alsman.
Warum war der jetzt da?
Der hatte nichts mit der Veranstaltung zu tun,
der hat nur zufällig, ist er ausgestiegen aus dem Auto.
Der hatte nichts damit zu tun.
Aber ich habe den ganzen Abend
darauf gewartet, ob nicht irgendwann es
heißt, und hier ist
Götz-Alsman und die ganzen
Dota-Fans. What fans what wer götz es war auf jeden fall er großartig aber ist nicht der mit dem weirdesten namen das muss man schon mal sagen bei dota ist er nicht ist götz nicht der mit dem weirdesten namen in allen anderen orten vielleicht war er deswegen da um einmal nicht der mit dem weirdesten namen zu sein ja wenn du in der hallee bist mit Leuten, die Mind Control heißen, denkst du dir schon, okay, gut, er hat vielleicht die weirdeste Frisur, aber nicht den weirdesten Namen. Und danach gab es noch so eine Fotowand mit allen Spielern und ich habe mich angestellt und ich war so aufgeregt, ich weiß gar nicht warum, ich war so aufgeregt. Und dann, das war wirklich so eine Massenabfertigung, so einmal in die Mitte und Foto.
Und ich war dann einmal kurz und ich habe nur gesagt, oh, thanks for the Fotos, habe irgendwo hingeguckt, komplett komisches Gesicht gemacht. War furchtbar, war mega aufgeregt, aber sehr dankbar. Das Problem ist, das Foto wurde von so einem Location-Fotograf gemacht und ich habe keine Ahnung, wie ich an dieses Foto rankommen soll. Was? Das heißt, ich muss mich jetzt erst mal auf die Quest machen, an dieses Foto zu kommen. Aber ich habe keine Ahnung, wie man da rankommt. Ich glaube, am Ende rufe ich das Kino einfach an oder irgendwie sowas. Aber es war auf jeden Fall ein Moment, den wir erkennen. Wir machen ja auch nach unseren Live-Shows immer noch Fotos. Und es ist natürlich auch interessant, immer auf der anderen Seite zu sein. Ja, natürlich. Voll spannend. Nicht jetzt jetzt uns mit OG zu vergleichen, mit den besten Dota-Spielen der Welt. Aber es war schon aufregend und man steht da und denkt einfach nur, guck nicht dumm, guck einfach nicht Bescheid. Guck einfach nicht Bescheid. Er macht nichts Dummes. Er macht jetzt nichts Dummes. Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha. Was macht mein Mund gerade? Hey, wow, wow, wow, wow, Mund, hey, hey, was machst du? What do hands do? Linke, linke Mundseite, wo, ja, what does mouth do?
Wie steht man? Was ist, stehe ich, das alles ist weird, das ist diese Frage, die man sich nicht stellen kann.
Genau, und du, alles ist unbequem, du denkst dir, wo kommen meine Mundwinkel eigentlich hin? Aber das sind die Momente, wo man alles hinterfragt, auch was machen Arme, warum brauche ich zwei Arme, warum hängen beide an mir herunter, warum sind die am denkbar höchsten Punkt angebracht an meiner Seite? Das sind die spannenden Fragen, die man sich darstellt in solchen Momenten und man sieht es den Fotos dann auch oft an, muss man sagen. Ja, und es ist dann wirklich so dieses Lächeln, Lächeln und dann merkt man so, du lächelst gar nicht, du ziehst einfach deine Mundwinkel nach hinten.
Normalerweise ist das Lächeln noch Mundwinkel nach dann merkt man so, du lächelst gar nicht, du ziehst einfach nur deine Mundwinkel nach hinten.
Normalerweise ist das Lächeln doch Mundwinkel nach oben oder du ziehst sie gerade einfach nur so nach hinten, als ob du deinen Mund so breit wie möglich machst. Und dann, okay, next, alles klar, dann denkst du, okay, fuck it, ich will dieses Bild nicht sehen, aber es war ein fantastischer Abend. Ich verstehe das ja immer nicht, warum man, also man muss ja auch sagen, wenn man nicht die Chance hat, mit denen noch zu reden. Wir reden ja dann auch noch mit den Leuten, die dann nach einer Live-Stoche zu uns kommen, kurz, zumindest, ist nicht mehr so möglich, aber wir versuchen das hinzubekommen und das, dann verstehe ich auch, warum sich die Leute anstellen und so. Bei einem Fototermin, wo man keine Chance hat, mit denen zu reden, hat ich zum Beispiel nie das Bedürfnis. Also ich war ja auch häufig mal bei der Star Wars Celebration in den USA und da haben Freunde von mir dann auch immer Fotos gemacht.
Die sind dann so zu Fotos, Foto-Opps gegangen und haben sich dann ganz lange angestellt, um dann ein Foto zu bekommen vor so einer Leinwand.
Und ich fand das ehrlich gesagt nie schön, auch diese Fotos zu haben, weil ich mir immer denke, die sind das Resultat von, ich habe dafür bezahlt, ich habe da lange angestanden, der Typ hatte keine Lust mehr, der hat mir nicht mal die Augen geguckt, der hat kurz seinen Arm ausgestreckt, den Arm um mich gelegt und in die Kamera guckt, wie er es bei allen anderen auch macht. Also wenn man jemanden zufällig trifft auf der Straße, dann verstehe ich das, aber diesen Reiz von Fotoopportunität habe ich noch nie ganz verstanden. Ja, es stimmt schon. Da ist nichts Besonderes dran. Ich habe mir auch erst gedacht so, weil ich dachte mir schon, ich habe gesehen, dass die Fotowand aufgebaut wurde ganz am Anfang und dachte mir, okay, nee, komm, mach's ja nicht, du bist jetzt nicht einer von denen. Aber danach denkst du dir einfach so, ich habe die Gelegenheit einmal in meinem Leben, warum nicht einfach noch jetzt die Stunde anstehen und es machen, weil es ist kein grosses Investment, es ist nicht viel und du hast dieses Foto und wenn es doof ist, dann mein Gott, so, aber du hast diese Möglichkeiten, die wieder und außerdem ist das vielleicht ein spezieller Anlass, weil wie gesagt, OG wird sich stark verändern und das war so ein bisschen das letzte Event als so das alte Team irgendwie und das wird es so nie wieder geben und deswegen dachte ich mir, komm, was soll's und dann, ja. Aber ich möchte, du gerne postest, das Foto, wenn das wie gesagt, ich weiß nicht, ob ich da rankomme, ich nehme mal an, das wird so sein, wie beim Neo Magazin auch, wo halt einfach sämtliche Bilder irgendwo hochgeladen werden, da gibt's ja auch immer so eine Fotowand vor der Show, wo man dann alle Fotos machen kann und die werden alle irgendwo hochgeladen und dann muss man sich halt seines raussuchen und ja, ich bin gespannt, wie das funktionieren wird, aber es war ... Ich verstehe auch nicht, Apple weiss ja, wie du aussiehst, weil ich hab dich ja auch schon mal auf allen Bildern angeklickt und dich Florentin Will genannt und mit deiner Handynummer verbunden. Ich verstehe nicht, warum es nicht einfach bei dir aufploppt jetzt in der Fotoroll, warum nicht alle Fotos, die im Internet sind, mit deinem Gesicht automatisch in deiner Fotoroll auftauchen? Weil Apple weiss ja schon mindestens mal, Google ja mit Sicherheit auch, wie du aussiehst. Aber das kommt hundertprozentig. Ich meine, es gibt ja auch so einen Google Alert für den Namen oder halt für jeden Begriff oder auch immer. Aber es gibt viele Leute, die haben den Google Alert auf ihren eigenen Namen, so dass man direkt immer eine Mail von Google bekommt, wenn irgendwo der Name erwähnt wird. Ich glaube, es muss eine gewisse Relevanzschwelle überstritten werden oder so. Aber dann kriegt man eine Mail und das wird ja wahrscheinlich auch irgendwann für Fotos gehen. Dass du einfach heisst, ein Foto von dir wird hochgeladen, dann kannst du vielleicht selber sogar, oh, da musst du sogar selber Bilder in der Datenbank hochladen. Und dann haben die dich, dann hat dich Google, dann haben die dich am Schlawittchen. Ja. Google, falls ihr zuhört, macht das. Macht das mal, das ist die geniale Idee. Ansonsten war es das für diese Woche und ich würde sagen, bevor wir gleich abheben, noch kurz die Bitte, schickt uns gerne Beiträge ein für Antenafrika, das ist wichtig, das soll unbedingt weitergehen. Wir haben nicht mehr so viele in petto, da kommen noch ein paar, wir müssen mal gucken, wie wir damit umgehen und achtet bitte darauf, dass sie nicht zu lang werben.
Und dann noch eine zweite Sache, und zwar sind wir für den Deutschen Podcastpreis nominiert, was uns sehr freut und ihr könnt da für uns abstimmen. Schaut einfach mal nach auf der Website deutscher-podcastpreis.de und da könnt ihr dann eure Stimme für uns
hinterlassen. Wir würden uns natürlich sehr darüber freuen. Ich glaube, man kann für mehrere abstimmen. Stimmt für
eure Podcast ab, die ihr gerne mögt und unterstützt die damit. Das ist doch schön. Ja, tut das ansonsten. Vielen
Dank an Christoph für das Intro. Schöne Woche, haut rein und wir sehen uns nächste Woche wieder. Bis dann, macht's gut und wir
heben ab. Bis dann.